what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
discussing the latest happenings in the
boku no hero story including the
long-awaited revelation about Dec whose
doctors true identity including his name
his real name
his quirk factor and how he has been
able to acquire the ingredients
necessary to manufacture the Nomo oh and
did I forgot to mention that we're also
in the middle of a massive hero
operation that could be the first battle
in a new total war arc in my hero
academia there is a lot to talk about
there is a lot on the line so let's get
into it if you enjoyed the boku no hero
content right here on the channel please
leave a like to let me know it
definitely helps and if you have it to
be new to anime abroad don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on Twitter and/or
Instagram at anime uproar finally there
will definitely be boku no hero manga
spoilers in this video as I mentioned
we're talking about the latest events in
the story so please proceed with caution
you have been warned
the cover of chapter 259 seems unrelated
to the rest of the chapter it just shows
Fuyumi Todoroki meeting Natsu at the
doorstep of their home the text reads
new life of Fuyumi and Natsu another
step towards being a family behind Natsu
we see a faint glimpse of a girl with
animal ears not sure this is maybe not
so girly and but I don't recall seeing
her before I am guessing that this brief
scene is going to be somehow related to
endeavour and his whole story arc up to
this point but I'm not exactly sure why
it was included with this chapter
however right after this cover we jump
right into the big stuff we see decos
doctor and a villain known by the alias
Daruma Fujiko but now we finally learn
his real name which is Shiga Morita and
interestingly enough we learned that the
doctor was apparently born quirk less or
at least that's what the official
information on him says but you never
know with a guy who's been working with
all-4-one the doctor is the founder and
CEO
of the jakku general hospital the name
of the hospital is another reference to
Star Wars by the way and we also learned
that for years the doctor has been
setting up orphanages nursing homes and
private clinics throughout the country
officially the doctor claims to be
interested in quirk based community care
and he is a well-known philanthropist in
his public persona the doctor is highly
respected because of his impressive
resume and his accomplishments but as we
all know he has been leading a double
life while pretending to be a
philanthropist and a renowned health
worker the doctor has been working with
all-4-one and the League of villains and
worst of all he has been creating the
nomu using human corpses although I
suspect that some of the normal like
Kudo Geary were not created from corpses
but from still living people we are then
transported into a large hero briefing
where su couchy is explaining all of the
information that they have gathered
about the doctor so catchy and the
police were able to unmask the doctor
and learn his troy'd enemy thanks in
large part to overdose clue about the
hospital after they received that clue
the police studied the blueprints of all
the hospitals in the country and they
found that the blueprints of one
hospital included a section that was
unlabeled and whose true purpose was
unknown to the hospital's employees this
secret section of the hospital is
accessible only through the morgue and
the only one who has access to it is
Shiga aka ug Co aka the doctor su kouchi
sent one of his men to work undercover
in this particular hospital and one day
while he was following the doctor su
cauchy's agent was able to snap a photo
of the secret section from a distance a
photo that also managed to capture a
glimpse of the tiny nomu known as Johnny
the Nommo who possesses the sludgy
warping work this is all to prove that
the police and the heroes needed to
arrest the doctor and it does make
perfect sense with a secret section of
the hospital that is accessible only by
the morgue and that only the doctor has
access to it would have been easy for
him and all for want to steal
the body of Oberoi and many other
innocent people and to then turn these
people into nomu without anyone ever
noticing so the interview with kudo
giddy back in Tartarus prison and the
clue about the hospital ended up being
absolutely instrumental in getting the
police to this point in their
investigation so kouchi says that the
doctor's arrest won't be difficult but
they can't mess it up because otherwise
the heroes on the other frontline will
be discovered before they have had a
chance to complete their own mission
that mission is of course to capture
shigaraki before he finishes powering up
and some other stuff that I'll talk
about soon and of course all of this
information about shigaraki was given to
the heroes by hawks after he received
the Intel from twice at this point we
also learned that the police and heroes
are fully aware of the existence and
actions of the paranormal Liberation
Front and in fact their goal is not only
to take the doctor and she kuraki off
the board but to take down the entire
Liberation Front in one fell swoop
this will require assaulting the mansion
where the leadership of the paranormal
Liberation Front meets an assault that
is set to take place at the same time as
the doctor's arrest a whole other group
of Heroes is apparently preparing for
the assault on the mansion a separate
group from the one we saw in the
previous chapter which featured
endeavour
Aizawa mahboy washa and so on the
endeavour group is presumably attacking
the hospital while I should say
attacking the hospital I mean they're
trying to arrest the doctor and while
this group is doing that the other group
is going to be attacking the mansion the
mansion group has everyone from Mount
Lady midnight
Kamui woods gang Orca fat gum headshot
and cement O's to students like
sun-eater and mushroom girl from class
1b aka Kinoko mori even heroes and
students from the other heroes schools
are here including members of the ketsu
bhutesu Academy so this is definitely a
national issue at this point and a major
nationwide operation some of the
students like mushroom girl community
and Tokyo Yami have actually been taken
to the frontlines rather than placed in
supporting roles like most of the other
students but the idea is apparently to
get them to use their powerful quirks to
help out a little bit in the beginning
and then retreat from the front
so that they would not be in danger not
sure if this is exactly how it's gonna
end up working out but according to
headshot they have surrounded the
villains from all sides and not even a
single one will be allowed to get away
this Sall definitely looks very good for
the heroes at the moment most of their
Intel has come from Hawkes so they know
the meeting times and places that the
villains use they know their routines
and movements and so on but in my
previous MHA video I said that I think
the heroes might be heading into a trap
I'll talk more about that later
but it all just seems far too convenient
at this point one word from Oberoi and
the Intel from Hawkes have seemingly led
to the unmasking of the entire
paranormal Liberation Front and the
heroes are now in position and preparing
to take the entire Liberation Front down
in one day this might be where the story
is really heading but after all of that
build-up that we've had for the villains
including shigaraki twice toga and so on
this just seems a bit too easy I think
that the villains still have something
up their sleeve I think that twice might
have been feeding some false Intel to
Hawks but we'll have to wait and see
whether my prediction is correct as
endeavour sets out on his mission the
citizens of the city are actively
noticing the strange lack of heroes on
the streets however they do finally see
one hero slide and go and he also seems
confused about why he can't see any
other heroes on the streets but we know
that sliding goal is not just a normal
hero he is a dedicated member of the
paranormal Liberation Front it is safe
to assume that thanks to hawks has
entailed the police and the heroes
deliberately kept all the Liberation
Front sympathizers out of the loop in
the next moment
sliding go is grabbed from behind by
death arms the punching hero death arms
call sliding go a treacherous liberation
devotee and he presumably takes slide
and go out of commission for the
remainder of the operation he is of
course the punching hero so expect he
will be doing quite a bit of punching
right about now the students from the
previous chapter who are being led by
burnin including of course Deku and many
of the students from class 1a
begin their evacuation operation as
endeavors team forces their way into the
hospital the man who had infiltrated the
hospital on su cauchy's orders leads
endeavour and the heroes straight to the
doctor the doctor is thinking to himself
that everything is going smoothly and
that shigaraki is under a month away
from being complete but he is then
stunned to see endeavour confront him
and expose him for being the normal
creator and all for one's right-hand man
the doctor looks shocked and scared as
endeavour calls out for him to give up
and calls him an agent of evil and that
is where the chapter ends clearly from
this last scene with the doctor it seems
that Fujiko was not expecting the heroes
to find him at this point in time before
he was confronted he thought about
everything going smoothly and then after
he is confronted he seems genuinely
freaked out and scared however as I said
earlier this whole thing just seems too
easy and too simple for my liking the
paranormal Liberation Front is a large
and powerful organization with
connections everywhere they have
supporters among the heroes among the
police among the politicians a new Chico
has spent much of his life being
extremely careful and hiding his
identity and true intentions masterfully
so is it really possible that the
villains have been caught completely by
surprise and that the heroes are about
to destroy the paranormal Liberation
Army in a single operation I think that
after all of this build-up for the
villains it would be far too
anticlimactic to have them just all go
down and now I am more inclined to
believe that there is still something
going on here that we are missing the
villains must have some trick up their
sleeve maybe twice fed some bad
information to Hawks in order to test
his loyalty and once Hawkes gave the
Intel to heroes the villains knew that
Hawkes was a spy and they decided to set
some sort of trap for the heroes I fully
admit that the reactions of slide and go
and the doctors seemed to suggest that
they were taken by surprise and that the
heroes managed to plan and execute this
operation without tipping off any
Liberation Front sympathizers but don't
forget that we still haven't seen any of
the other villains
this chapter we haven't seen shigaraki
we haven't seen twice toga Dhabi get in
and the rest of the Liberation Front I
sincerely doubt that they are all just
sitting ducks waiting to be surrounded
and taken into custody by the heroes I
would wager that there is more going on
here than meets the eye but what exactly
is going on I'm not really sure I you
find it difficult to believe that any of
the doctors plans or potential traps
would involve him getting exposed and
captured after he went through all that
trouble to lead a double life and hide
his identity but then again something
might have changed in the meantime
perhaps the doctor needs to take a big
risk in order to accomplish something
specific and perhaps he has some high
and nomu hidden inside the hospital and
waiting for the heroes to show up again
I fully acknowledge that things do look
pretty bad for Chico and the Liberation
Front as of chapter 259 the only way
that things could turn around for them
now is if there are some factors at play
here that we as the readers are not
currently aware of I'm willing to bet
that this is the case but that is just
my personal opinion let me know what you
guys think did the heroes really just
get the jump on the liberation front and
are they about to take the villains down
or is there some important piece of the
story that we are still missing
did the heroes end up getting lured into
a dangerous trap without even realizing
it personally I've always felt that Kudo
Giddy's capture and imprisonment was
highly suspicious It was as if Carew
giddy wanted to be caught and sent to
Tartarus the same prison where all for
one and all the other major villains are
located
it was also kudo giddy who then revealed
the information that led to this entire
operation an operation that involves so
many heroes I wouldn't be surprised if
all of this hospital stuff is a red
herring and I wouldn't be surprised if
all for one uses this major distraction
to orchestrate a Tartarus Prison Break
using of course Kudo godís quirk which
he is able to forcibly activate even if
Kudo giddy is unconscious with all of
these heroes and heroes students
preoccupied with the Liberation Front
operation the security of Tartarus must
be lower than
would be on a normal day and I am sure
that the response to a major prison
break would also be much slower now
because so many heroes are off on
special assignment but that is just my
conspiratorial take feel free to share
your thoughts down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video you want to
see more boku no hero action right here
on the channel please leave a like to
let me know and if you happen to be new
to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications seriously
be sure to go through the trouble of
turning on all notifications otherwise
you're gonna miss a lot of our videos
it's just how you do works you can
follow me on Twitter and or Instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest boku no
hero news and updates I want to give a
big thank you to all of our anime opera
patrons who support our content and make
these videos possible first up let me
thank our the one tier patrons the ones
who rise above all other clans including
Ingrid ah a Lola nada makoto-kun the
world stealers the school bus and Tyson
quit Ino I also can't forget our awesome
pro hero tier patrons including the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson kings el dress very dolla
beat alpha do
Anatoli Cassatt's ki on hell Cruz team
Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor otaku Timothy a
vodkas Jean d'Arc
and Joe Stanton if you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value for
you consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our page and exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these legendary people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]